just over 24 hours after he brought fear
to the streets of birmingham
walk downstairs zephaniah mcleod was
arrested by armed police
he'd gone out in the early hours armed
with a knife and chose eight victims at
random the first man he stabbed managed
to run away twenty minutes later he
struck again
after stabbing a third victim he put his
knife down a drain and took a taxi four
miles home
but there he re-armed himself and headed
back to the city center
his next victims were best friends jacob
billington and michael callahan
he's losing a lot of blood from the neck
is he breathing unconscious
he's conscious okay not really he's
losing consciousness
mcleod calmly walked away as jacob lay
dying he'd been on a night out to
celebrate a friend's birthday
i can still see him leaving the house
with the lads in the car outside beeping
the horns getting to hurry up and he
skipped out and we just thought he was
going for a
you know a lovely night out with his
friends
we just got a knock on the door from the
police in the very early hours it was
absolutely awful
um i could
i could break you feel like you had all
the breath sucked out of your is the
best way you can describe it there were
just no words to kind of describe
the kind of
sadness that i felt like sadness doesn't
even do it justice you know
this is someone who i've
shared my life with
jacob's friend michael survived but only
just
he spent more than six months in
hospital and some of his injuries will
be permanent but he was determined to be
at court to see his friend's killer
jailed jacob billington was the best of
zeph and i us
a cloud
is a liar and a murderer
his mother says macleod should never be
released
not answered any questions he's not
talked about it we don't know anything
about why he did what he did
how can anybody stay safe again i don't
think anybody can mcleod has paranoid
schizophrenia these weren't his first
defenses he told a string of
professionals that he hears voices that
tell him to hurt people and yet he was
released from prison in april 2020 the
height of the first wave of the pandemic
with no mental health support he was the
judge said simply lost in the system
the warning signs missed jacob's family
want to know why
you know the fact that he didn't appear
to have been monitored in the way that
you would imagine he would
as somebody was known to be dangerous
and had a long previous history of being
dangerous
a serious case review is looking at why
people knew he was a threat yet nothing
was done until it was too late becky
johnson sky news birmingham